[Music]
[Applause]
we didn't have Lincoln tonight did you
want to see him did you want to address
what happened with him or why wasn't he
here no no I I did not want him here nor
did he deserve to earn the right to be
here he forfeited that right obviously
with what he did and lying to us and
deceiving everybody and so no I'm very
glad that he was not here and was not
extended an invitation Garret has
released this statement on Instagram
apologizing for some things that
happened on Instagram have you spoken
him at all and what do you think about
the way that he responded to the
situation I have spoken to Garrett and
and one thing I do want to clear up too
is that Garrett and Lincoln should not
be in the same sentence Garrett did
something that you don't agree with or
that a lot of people don't agree with
and that's fine that is your prerogative
and it might be mine too that's not
against the law what Lincoln did was
against the law very different I've
talked to Garrett beca's talk to Garrett
we've all talked to Garrett and I feel
like he expressed himself very well and
I don't think it'll be the end of it
obviously he's still in the midst of all
this I think he'll express more about
that and we'll probably be able to deal
with it more okay he is doing good and
I'm so so far I'm satisfied with what he
had to say in what I said what he said
to me personally and again you'll have
to be the judge for yourself
you